after months of sneak peeks and teases
Disney has finally released the first
official trailer for its live adaptation
of Aladdin we're again greeted by a few
familiar faces as well as several new
things we've not seen from the 1992
original here's everything you need to
know about the new trailer for a ladder
the new trailer is chock-full of moments
that will make you reminisce about the
original animation
it begins with Aladdin's first
introduction as he's chased by three
city guards across the city through the
streets and over the roof in the
original it was for stealing a loaf of
bread which he carries prominently
throughout the chase giving us a few
comedic moments like this one but it's
clearly missing from the movies so why
is Aladdin being chased something else
that seems to be missing from the scene
is one of the very first scores of
Aladdin one jump ahead which really
introduces Aladdin as a character along
with his backstory from the rest of the
trailer it's clear we'll definitely see
some of the original musical scores so
could this possibly mean that we might
not get all the musical numbers from the
original in the film we also get a more
comprehensive look at the familiar faces
from the original we see Rajah Jasmine's
pet tiger once again walking
majestically down the steps along with
jasmine but for a split second we also
see him protecting jasmine from the
palace cons probably after Jafar has
taken over the Empire with genies help
we also see the magic carpet in action
helping Aladdin multiple times from
danger and also in this iconic scene but
more on that later
Yago Jafar's parrot that we've seen
flying from behind in every single
trailer finally makes his front sight
debut and he's huge most likely from
Jafar's magic chasing Aladdin and Abu
across the city and of course Genie who
was the center of controversy after his
first appearance we definitely see more
of genies charm
and wit's in this trailer as well as
some of the incredible magic he performs
and speaking of genie it's impossible
not to go over the masterful original
scores that make a reappearance in the
film like Will Smith performing friend
like me with the same magical visuals
from the original and of course one of
the most memorable musical numbers in
all of Disney's animation a whole new
world and although we don't get to hear
it it's obvious that we'll see a
performance of Prince Ali here is
Aladdin disguised as a prince makes his
return to the city without a doubt the
new adaptation of Aladdin is aware and
reminiscent of its predecessor just like
all of Disney's recent live adaptations
but that doesn't mean Disney hasn't
taken any creative liberties and some
are a little more worrisome than others
the choice to magically enlarge Iago for
an epic chase scene makes sense
films director Guy Ritchie is known for
his stylish visuals and epic set pieces
but the decision to let genie have a
human form is questionable sure it lets
us know that it's Will Smith who is the
only recognizable face in a cast full of
newcomers but it doesn't make much sense
other than showing Will Smith as himself
on screen not to mention it will make
Aladdin fring genie feel much less
impactful the same goes for the scene
where Jafar brings Aladdin to the Cave
of Wonders
but as himself unlike the original where
he disguised himself as an old man to
trick Aladdin it's a subtle yet
important plot point in the original
that really gives us an idea of what
kind of a man Jafar really is without
subtle moments like this it's possible
that your farm might be another flat
villain simply there to progress the
story Disney's live adaptations have
been most successful when they merge the
traditions of the original with
forward-thinking changes it's a tricky
balance and the changes we've witness
so far and the trailer are worrisome to
say the least so what did you think
about the trailer what are you most
excited about are you okay with the
creative liberties they took with a
story and is Jeannie still creepy tell
us in the comments below